de tout temps on a cherché à se
débarrasser des déjections humaines
comme l'urine dans nos maisons modernes
on tire la chasse et on y pense plus
mais de plus en plus des chercheurs à
travers le monde s'intéressent au fait
de séparer l'urine du reste des eaux
usées c'est encore un petit échelle
expérimental mais le potentiel pour
l'agriculture existe bel et bien
voilà bienvenue sur le site de
Saint-Vincent de Paul
en plein cœur de Paris plus de 30 000
mètres carrés de chantier de terrain
vague deviendront bientôt le plus vaste
éco quartier de la France et le site
d'une expérience environnementale unique
au monde le recyclage à grande échelle
de l'urine humaine on va retrouver ici
un quartier de logement avec 600
logements 1200 habitants une école une
crèche un gymnase des locaux d'activités
une fondation d'art contemporain
tout construction qui vont être
raccordés à un système de collecte
d'urine à la source
1200 habitants ça représente autour de
300000 litres d'urine par année une
montagne de déchets qui en temps normal
et dirigé vers l'usine d'épuration
mais à Saint-Vincent de Paul se déchait
pas plutôt être transformé en une
ressource du bio fertilisant
au fond c'est pas très éloigné de la
collecte sélective enfin du recyclage
des ordures ménagères avant on mettait
tout dans une même boîte et on y pense
plus et maintenant on a au moins la
conscience de se dire à ça et ce qui va
vraiment finir au fond d'une décharge ou
est-ce que je vais donner sa chance à ce
produit
pour y arriver il faut revoir
complètement le système classique de
gestion des eaux usées terminez la
toilette conventionnelle connectée au
réseau d'acqueduc public puis à l'usine
d'épuration
les toilettes vous permettront de
participer à une agriculture plus
durable le nouveau quartier sera plutôt
équipé de toilettes spécialement conçue
pour séparer l'urine d'un aqueduc en
circuit fermé et en bout de ligne d'une
micro usine de fabrication d'engrais un
modèle unique qui intéresse déjà
plusieurs pays européens ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'au-delà de la ville
de Paris même des projets qui étaient
simplement en germes depuis quelques
années
passent l'accélérateur parce qu'ils ont
vu que la Ville de Paris s'est engagée
sur la thématique et c'est donc qu'il se
disent c'est sérieux on peut y aller si
la ville de Paris le fait il faut qu'on
le fasse aussi
Paris s'est engagé à utiliser tout le
bio engrais produit à Saint-Vincent de
Paul pour fertiliser ses espaces verts
dont le magnifique jardin du Luxembourg
a deux pas du quartier bien sûr on veut
pas s'arrêter au parc des jardins de la
ville de Paris on a la chance d'avoir ce
déboucher là qui nous permet de montrer
que c'est possible mais ce qu'on vise
c'est l'agriculture
on sait depuis très longtemps que
l'urine humaine est un excellent
fertilisant naturel qui peut améliorer
les rendements aux champs
à Paris pour préserver l'eau de la scène
la ville a longtemps géré un système
élaboré de récupération et de transport
de l'urine de ses citoyens vers les
zones agricoles
des pratiques qui ont disparu avec la
mise en place des réseaux modernes de
traitement des eaux usées il y a
beaucoup d'exemples en Chine dans les
Flandres au Pays-Bas où on avait des
systèmes pour un million d'habitants 10
millions d'habitants où on avait des
collectes des urines et matières fécales
et tout un commerce de ces matières
comme matière fertilisantes pour
l'agriculture
suit un banlieue de Paris l'École des
Ponts est l'une des plus grandes
facultés de génie en France depuis 5 ans
Fabien sculliez son équipe travaille à
recréer l'ancienne filière de
récupération à la source de l'urine à la
moderniser et à la réintroduire en
milieu agricole c'est une tâche complexe
c'est effectivement un grand défi c'est
que on a perdu c'est pratique et du coup
on a perdu aussi les éléments
logistiques qui permettent de le faire
donc il faut recomposer ces éléments
petit à petit ils ont un double objectif
réduire l'utilisation des fertiles
synthèse et diminuer le volume et le
coût du traitement des eaux usées
aujourd'hui on a conscience des limites
de la production d'engrais de synthèse
qui sont très émissifs en gaz à effet de
serre qui nécessitent beaucoup d'énergie
et on a conscience aussi des limites de
la préservation de l'eau à la fois en
termes de consommation d'eau et puis de
qualité de l'eau dans les rivières
sur papier leur projet tient la route
une adulte produit en moyenne de 300 à
500 litres d'urine par année
95% du liquide est constitué d'eau mais
le récit riche en minéraux comme le
potassium le phosphore et l'azote les
éléments clés de la fertilisation des
sols les tests réalisés en milieu
agricole ont également démontré que ce
biou fertilisant dépasse en efficacité
les engrais organiques classiques et
s'approche des engrais minéraux
si on collectait l'urine des 10 millions
d'habitants qui constituent aujourd'hui
l'agglomération parisienne et comprenez
cette urine pour fertiliser du blé on
pourrait produire de quoi faire 25
millions de baguettes de pain chaque
jour c'est à dire une quantité qui est
colossale
selon son estimée une gestion efficace
permettrait de remplacer 20% des 18
millions de tonnes d'engrais chimiques
qu'on utilise chaque année en Europe
mais de la théorie à la pratique la
marche est encore haute sur le plan
sanitaire et réglementaire mais aussi
celui de l'acceptabilité sociale il faut
déjà dépasser à un enjeu j'ai envie de
dire de d'aprriver un peu négatif c'est
pas évident quand même de dire qu'on va
utiliser du ring etc on peut avoir une
forme de rejet donc il y a un peu de
barrière psychologique mais cette
barrière n'est pas un franchissable
toupie organique est l'une des rares
entreprises européennes qui fabriquent
et commercialise un bio fertilisant à
base d'urine un premier produit qui a
été développé qui s'appelle le lactopie
Start qui est ni plus ni moins que de
l'urine fermenté avec des bactéries à
l'intérieur qui permettent de réduire le
besoin en phosphore qu'on apporte dans
le champ
il y a beaucoup de phosphore dans les
sols donc si on amène nos bactéries ça
permet à la plante de capter ce soir
lors de notre passage l'entrepôt
débordait 80 000 litres de matière
première récupérer durant la période
estivale à l'aide de toilettes portables
installés sur des lieux très fréquentés
de la région de Bordeaux gare de train
place publique concert musicaux
le tout doit d'abord être stocké
quelques semaines avant d'être filtré
stabilisé pasteurisé et finalement
transférer dans ces grandes cuves de
fermentation le processus de
transformation fait qu'on a une urine
qui est qui est retirée dans laquelle
toutes les impuretés donc les restes
midi 402 les restes de drogue par
exemple des choses comme ça
donc des gens dans l'urine qui est
propre et ensuite qui est chargé en
bactéries en levure en champignons en ce
qu'on veut
en 2022 l'entreprise a obtenu le feu
vert pour la vente de ses produits dans
5 pays européens
mais le patron sait que ce type de
biophertisant est encore très peu connu
on nous pose toujours des questions qui
sont normales c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'il
y a est-ce que vous arrivez à enlever
les antibiotiques est-ce que vous
arrivez à enlever les hormones c'est
vendu à quel prix est-ce que c'est
efficace mais ça c'est des questions
légitimes
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique au
Vermont l'équipe du reach Heart
Institute un organisme sans but lucratif
a choisi une autre approche travailler
directement avec la communauté et les
agriculteurs
sur ce sujet surtout en milieu
universitaire mais sur le terrain nous
sommes le plus gros programme de
collecte et de recyclage d'urine aux
États-Unis
puis 2011 les suabots local de
récupération
le gros camion de collecte fait
maintenant partie des icônes de la
communauté sur une base régulière on se
rend aux adresses des participants qui
ont le réservoir est plein la collecte
sert aux besoins en recherche et
développement du groupe
on a un laboratoire du financement
gouvernemental et des collaborateurs
universitaires
ou participe des représentants d'une
trentaine de pays
[Musique]
le cadre réglementaire du Vermont exige
que les chercheurs effectuent
régulièrement les contrôles de qualité
sur la présence de résidus de
médicaments ou de métaux lourds on sait
que la présence de métaux lourds dans
les bouts d'épuration peut représenter
un problème mais dans l'urine qu'on
récupère nos tests indiquent les
vraiment très faible on parle de
concentration un millier de fois plus
bas que les limites jugées sécuritaires
[Musique]
les tissus collaborent également avec un
groupe d'agriculteurs de la région
la terre de Jay Belly un éleveur de
chevaux sert de bander pour évaluer
différentes formules et concentration
sur ces pâturages
expérimentations il estime que ce bio
fertilisant a fait ses preuves
est là la demande va suivre et que pas
mal tous les agriculteurs vont être prêt
à utiliser cette méthode
mais avant d'en arriver là il reste une
barrière à franchir et c'est
probablement la plus haute
les agriculteurs demandent toujours
comme un vont réagir les consommateurs
en apprenant que leurs produits a été
fertilisé avec de l'urine
c'est le cas de sceller dessus que
l'équipe de l'Institut fait pousser à
l'intérieur durant la saison froide
ce sont des laitues qui poussent en
hydroponie l'azote est fournie par
l'urine purifiée et pasteurisée alors
que le phosphore est le potassium
proviennent d'un compost de verre de
terre
et comme vous pouvez le voir les plans
sont en excellente santé et les feuilles
délicieux au bout
le marché des bio fertilisant à base
d'urine est encore un secteur en friche
reconnaît le chercheur
mais une fois bien encadré et
socialement accepté il pense que l'idée
a le potentiel pour faire un bon bout de
chemin
les gens urinent tous les jours et qu'on
le veuille ou non il faut recycler toute
cette urine donc si on parvient à la
récupérer et à la Transformer localement
puis en faire un fertilisant économique
et efficace ça me semble un argument
convaincant
[Musique]
en 2006 l'OMS l'Organisation Mondiale de
la Santé a publié un guide sur
l'utilisation de l'urine en agriculture
à petite échelle elle est déjà employée
dans plusieurs pays d'Afrique
subsaharienne pour fertiliser les champs
c'est une pratique qui permet des
économies considérables parce que
l'urine remplace des engrais les enjeux
les plus importants pour éviter la
contamination par des pathogènes c'est
l'entreposage selon les contextes il
faut laisser reposer l'urine de 1 à 6
mois avant de l'utiliser